live hello good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever the hell you are
in the world and welcome to Sidra your
Sci-Fi TV movie channel and you can do
you can do your bit hello I'm Michael
Ball I'm uh on uh today live which is
actually throwing me obviously I'm on Co
Cloud on YouTube and uh today we've
actually uh joining forces to do a
special live stream talking about those
wonderful Star Trek movies or not so
wonderful Star Trek movies we'll have to
decide won't we I think it's fair to say
there a little bit of a mixed bag when
it comes to St movies I do agree
entirely very very big scale throw out a
ball straight away which because we
haven't prepared this particularly we we
know discuss what we're going to do um
have I spelled Co clud right by the way
you have mean the day I created my
channel back in uh 2007 I was just
trying to think of a name and the most
random word came into my head ccloud
people have asked is it from Wales is it
from wherever it is a completely random
word it doesn't mean anything it means
my channel whatever that means great
that's fine um right so obviously you
can go and find us if you're if you're
join us through sidet trk you can go
find C at cud if you join through cud
you can find us s so absolutely so first
of all big question what is the one St
Star Trek movie I check say C Star Trek
movie you wouldn't watch if you had a
choice we're gonna have to watch all of
them over the next couple of weeks
because we're then going to review each
of them I should say that start again
okay right so next couple of
months we're gonna watch all the Star
Trek movies and we're GNA rate them and
we want to get you guys to help us
figure out how we're going to rate them
um we're gonna do a scoring system I've
already thought of the Kirk for how many
girls get slept with no sorry action I
think we'll do action okay action might
be better but um oh oh how many girls
get um
and but I haven't watched any of the
movies in years and years so um we're
just we just wanted to do a little bit
of a what do we remember what are the
highs and lows that remember bad things
yeah yeah that's it pretty much is one
movie that you're not looking forward to
watching or the the one you're least
looking for uh okay if I could choose it
would probably have to be Star Trek five
the final frontier the search for God
yes basically yes Shak and all this sort
of stuff it was bard of all yeah I'm
going to throw a curveball I don't hate
that movie I actually quite like bits of
it I don't I like everything in every s
single Star Trek movie I like something
about it but um I okay for me it's the
motion
picture straight out the bat I find it
incredibly
boring and the bit where spot goes my
mind to your mind with a fcking Cloud
just I just does my heading is that the
bit when he sort of touches the eyo and
sort of go like that mind
M um I I thought the um I quite like the
V thing even though it was kind of
stupid where all of the early Star Trek
movies got something stupid in them that
work
somehow for you CH stupid movie from
beginning to end but somehow it was just
brilliant um
but for me I just find it's not that the
motion picture is a bad film it's not
pacing it's pacing it's
boring my man I'm old enough I actually
went to see it at the cinema in 1979 in
I think it was the Kingston Cinema in in
London where I'm originally from well
Southwest London just out of it and I
went with my uncle my mom I'm Manan I'm
Manan fell
State and uh yeah
when Star Trek first Contact came out I
went to a
Treon they basically showed all the
movies from beginning to end right okay
yeah so about four o'clock in the
morning we got to Voyage we got to the
final frontier and I have to admit I
slept through most of
it yeah a bit of a bit of a tall order
to go through all those movies isn't it
I mean yeah the literally overnight we
had breakfast and then we watched
Nemesis sorry first Contact first
Contact we got to see and and you know
how the British are quite emotionally
restrained I think it's fair to say of
course when first Contact came out
though we didn't have like nowadays with
like leaks online and all this sort
thing so nobody had actually seen the
ENT you would actually get surprises
yeah well we'd only seen the Enterprise
from like on the poster there was a and
you could see but you couldn't really
tell what it you know anything class
yeah exactly when the soving class came
out of the nebula and they did
that oh everybody in the the place
went really they actually GoPed really
yeah think I go oh whoa whoa We're
British all right oh this Ralph ride it
I've been arguing with you all day let's
let's have a little bit of a Stargate
moment okay go for it Ralph
believes and he's accused me repeatedly
of ignoring him and I haven't ignored
him I just don't care enough to thing
out but anyway Ralph believes that after
Stargate Continuum all of the gold world
are dead
that they're
extinct and I have an arguing that no
they're bloody
not bar system Lords are gone but there
are still lesser gold out there yes
sorry that's way I say it sorry yeah so
Ralph I'm sorry mate but you're wrong
stop going on about it apparently in one
line he says oh to to to to um T you're
um the gold are gone now you're free
and he's took that to mean literally
they're all gone and I think even I I
mean I watched Continuum the other day
they say system Lord repeatedly yeah
yeah yeah that's what I just said yeah
yeah but more importantly anyway even if
they did say gone it just means like as
a power they are defeated they are gone
as a power in the universe but they are
not
gone I'm sorry mate but they are not
defeat they're defeated not extinct they
still can I make a parallel with Star
Wars with the Contemporary Star Wars
series of La think where the Empire is
defeated but there are still remnants of
the Empire out there so it's it's it's a
similar
premise still the background you know
what I mean if I W drove to Parliament
and murder all the
MPS the British government is gone but
the British people still exist yes if
we'd still be here the government and
the the the hierarchy of the Gold World
Is Gone the Gold World System Lords are
gone they're defeated as a power in the
universe they're not dead and it's TK
not
tilac I'm sorry are you um are you
suggesting that all politicians are
acting like they've got snakes in their
heads or something like that it would
explain a few
things um but Ralph I'm sorry mate I I
don't want to have a have a moan at you
but you're wrong please stop going on
about it um right Star
Trek um oh he's called me a hypocrite in
all sorts days actually really start to
wipe me up a little bit um you just
won't admit it that you're wrong I'll
stay out of it this is obviously some a
situation um from outside so I'm looking
from an outside perspective a little bit
of a situation and because I don't want
it I just don't want the guy
to wrong and he's just need get yeah
find an agreement St St go on
um the and we will discuss the new Star
Treks in a minute that's a very very
good
point JJs we do need to throw in these
JJs what is the film out the classic
Star Trek who won't include the
JJs what is the one that you're looking
forward to
rewatching now the most likely answer
would be Star Trek to the wrath of KH
but I was always had a soft spot for
Star Trek 3 The Search for Spock um I
think it was a very very uh great
continuation from such a great previous
movie we see the destruction of the
Enterprise for the first time ever in
Star Trek um and uh you got Christopher
Lloyd as a Kling on I mean there's a lot
of good stuff in that movie he was
fantastic as a klling on he was the one
thing I like about that as well it was
like that that that was the two films
that were set up after the motion
picture did quite well and then Star
Wars did really really well so they they
they set up for two I actually think I
think the Voyage Home is part of I think
it's connected to it's like a Trilogy
yeah I get that and that was glorious
but I mean particularly The Wrath of
Khan and then the search for spark could
definitely like that's a two-parter
basically and we don't see that in
movies I love that
um normally to answer this
question I say the Undiscovered Country
because the Undiscovered Country is my
favorite okay yeah yeah I'm only old
enough to have gone to watch the
Undiscovered Country at the C that was
1991 1991 well I snuck out of school and
I actually skyed at school did you I'm
my mom isn't watching this and I sat in
the cinema on an afternoon with one
other bloke sat way way away from me in
my school uniform and watch in
discovered country and I was absolutely
Blown Away the opening
sequence theel prce yeah I just blew my
mind was I what was I in 1991 how old
was I uh I'd have been 13 I would have
been 19 18 19 yeah 13 so um
fantastic
but I haven't watched the Voyage Home in
years going back to your experience of
seeing the movie I went to see Star Trek
4 as well in the cinema and I remember
very clearly that when the movie ended
um and the end credits are going people
were all clapping in the cinema it went
down that well and I remember and I
think it's still one of the highest
rated star Tre movies at that time just
because it was more accessible to
mainstream it was more of a mainstream
movie than you know sort um so yeah
subject 4 has got I like the comedy I
like the fact that it's a time travel
yeah and um as as you said it was based
on it was like the trilogy of movies and
it could have been four but start with
the final frontier kind of was like in
the middle it kind of I don't know it's
a yeah it's a a movie on own isn't it
but um I I love it I think because well
you know how good it is because
basically they've been remaking it ever
since um you could argue that parts of
peard season 2 were just a remake of um
the Undiscovered Country or at least
they they took the plot of Undiscovered
Country and went not uncovered country
sorry a voyage home and just sort of
went we'll just yeah we'll do a bit of
time travel yeah we'll do wandering
around Los Angeles we'll do oh sorry San
Francisco yes little bit it was it was
yeah yeah also you had the guy on the
bus who was in Star Tre the voyage
as well yeah which is a nice little an
adult um so yeah I think
um I think the Voyage Home is the one
I'm looking forward to watching the most
because I know I I always loved it when
I was a kid that was the one I love the
most KH obviously I mean the WRA of
KH it's not just a good Star Trek movie
it's just a good movie full stop I mean
it's it does it's not just a Star Trek
movie it's just it's just well paced
well acted um yeah it's just it's just a
very again it's another accessible movie
um and it's it's like I said Star Trek
has always been a bit different from
Star Wars where a lot of people find it
a bit harder to get into Star Trek Star
Wars you could just watch it you got
lightsabers you got Space Battles and
it's although it's got its own world I I
think that's why Star Wars is so much
bigger than Star Trek for the general
audience um but Star Trek 2 was
referenced by the popular popular sort
of um fast PAC Star Wars which is why
start 2 they learned from the motion
picture going back to the slow pacing
you know what I mean yeah KH that's it
that's it um have you actually think
about the story lines for these movies
though right oh Earth attacked by big
cloud that was actually
Voyager um Earth sorry no and then the
Genesis thing was was a bit of a stretch
Planet Creator plan destroy the same one
KH comes back the whole thing about the
planet one Planet exploded and kicked
another planet over and the Federation
didn't realize no but that's kind
brilliant the Search for Spock we're we
we're basically going to put a brain
back into another and it's lucky that he
was on the Genesis Planet so his body
regenerated and they found him just at
the right age for um the Voyage Home
we're GNA get attacked by somebody
looking for Wales so we go back in time
and they
coming and think stupid storyline five
of a country actually just
oh no no yeah yeah undiscovered
countries are politically
drama and then you got into sort of
generations which is a the Nexus every
storyline is ridiculous but for some
reason still like them I still like it
all I I can't explain why it is
because I it's weird with the sort of
shows because you know there are some
really strange Concepts in all these
shows we watch and to people out like
what the hell are they watching but I
just like I love the Nexus in Star Trek
7 the generations I thought it was a
really and I thought it was a great link
between the Next Generation and the end
of the original movies it really was a
proper link I really enjoy Generations a
Generations really was one of the real
high up movies for me always we'll talk
about the tngg movies in a sec but let's
answer Williams question are we in
agreement that the even numbered Star
Trek are better than the odd-numbered
ones and I'll I'll put the comment away
because it's cutting off the bottom of
your face but right so even numbered
better right so I've already said I
don't like the motion picture I find it
boring I'm not looking forward to
watching it KH is brilliant yeah Search
for Spock is good I like that
one and then four yeah sorry the Voyage
Home is is is still one of my favorites
five bad six
great seven out of the newer films seven
is we weaker it's not a bad film I
actually really enjoy Generations but it
is
weaker first Contact yeah that's a big
probably the best of the new
Insurrection is terrible I didn't like
Insurrection Nemesis I like bits I like
NE I I like Nemesis I quite it's got a
great space battle part it they're not
great yeah but I I agree I think
actually the odd even the curse of the
odd has been that thing it's been a
curse isn't it it has been that I think
that for the majority of that those case
or examples you're right I think the uh
I think is the only odd is the only is
the only one that stands out really
because I think St is bful I think it's
it's it's really good and like I said I
like I like Generations number seven as
well so well the new the new Tre One S
because I mean Generations is seen as
one of the weaker movies but I actually
thought I don't agree with that no I
actually thought bill shman was great in
it yeah um but I I love William Shatner
I think he's brilliant one of my
favorite TV shows ever made is um Boston
Legal with William Shatner and um J TJ
hooker TJ hooker when I was a kid I
loved TJ I've got all the TJ TJ hookers
no um my wife bought me the Fall Guy
DVDs for Christmas oh no I've not seen
the Fall Guy actually I've not seen that
oh and there's this chicken there's this
blonde chicken that I loved she was she
was my favorite person um but yeah there
was um and thingy was in um TJ hook w't
she um oh Heather is it Heather oh my
God okay that was I was a teenage boy I
mean come on um but yeah so but I think
Generations the ending sequence is
fantastic I thought the whole bit with
data was a bit weak um I was not a
massive fan of the data
chip it's yeah it was a bit of a sort of
um unnecessary addition to the movie it
wasn't really needed um I think Brent it
was great to see him with emotions but I
don't know whether that really was um I
say the cenal to the story I think that
was a weaker part but it didn't quite
work no it didn't whether it
was I like the bit where he's scared
when um saon saon I was gonna say I want
to say Sauron but I'm like no
that's when sain is he gets frightened
so he doesn't help yeah he has that
weird gun that go like that cool that
folded yeah yeah I did like that bit I
like the idea of the um destroying the
star I thought that was a really very
powerful very cool weapon and it's the
sort of thing the robins would love MH
um so you know the main thing I didn't
like oh so I like the starting sequence
when they're on the oh the Enterprise B
was pretty cool oh the whole bit with
Enterprise B I mean that's a long memes
um meme won't be ready until Tuesday um
you know I mean that was a brilliant
sequence oh yeah the bit I didn't like
about it is it was the start of dark
Trek when they seemed to I I can only
assume that at Paramount they hadn't
paid their electric bill which is
actually probably quite likely because
there in a lot of financial struck um
and they just didn't turn the lights on
the whole film was very
dark
um just not not particularly well lit
and and we're used to it now with like
discovery not sorry mate you still there
yeah yeah yeah I'm here you I lost you
for a second did I okay should be back
in a second
yeah no I've got you we can hear
you dark TR yeah sure what I mean when
Jay's comes back I mean obviously um uh
oh here we are Jay's I think Jay's back
here we go mate you right I didn't go
anywh oh did you see me the whole time
yeah you whistling to yourself yeah yeah
you just
disappeared all right sorry the last
thing heard what it was the beginning of
of dark Trek so continue from that point
sorry so yeah I mean I just like to say
that par had been paying the electric
bill they turn all the lights off for
some reason and the whole movie is just
very dark we're used to that with Star
Trek Discovery strange new worlds Etc
now not so much strange new worlds but
where nobody seems to turn the lights on
Generations I think was the first one to
do that and it was a very different tone
a very different style to the rest of
the film and I have to admit I didn't
love
it yeah I mean as you say I mean you
look Voyager you look at um Next
Generation it was very bright sets and
the original series as well um I think
they assume they were trying to make it
more atmospheric I don't know why they
went there and of course the recently
card series was the darkest series ever
um so I don't know I don't know why they
started to go that direction but as you
say it did continue on from that point
um which is a shame it is it is sad
because it was it didn't it didn't work
and that was the that was the that's the
truth of it but but um I I I think it
must have been like a tonal thing they
wanted to separate it from the C the TV
series maybe it was making more make it
more cinematic um I love the the Gan not
Gan I love the duras sisters I thought
they were great l b isn't it yeah um and
I thought they were great I I actually
really did like the attack on the
Enterprise I thought that was great I
loved I loved all the different bits of
it it just overall it wasn't as good
for me um do you wish you'd see more of
like because obviously it's only um Kirk
that went we saw bicard I mean most
people would like seeing a proper thing
with like both the ships meeting up
somehow in some time thing and that
might been good but it was a bit
separated from the yeah that would have
been cheesy but I mean the whole Nexus
thing made no sense at all but um but
we'll we'll ignore that as well um I
just good film I hated seeing the
Enterprise destroyed but you know that
whole sequence was
phenomenal um and yeah it's not good but
we then went into first Contact yeah and
also technically only half the
Enterprise was Destroy but yeah I know
mean first Contact first Contact they
rescued the sorcer section and she flew
again but um but yeah um first Contact
for me
is again that's that's like um KH for me
it's that's not just a good film that's
a that you know it's not a good Star
Trek film that's a good film I mean
anybody would go in and enjoy that movie
it was phenomenally good um what they
did with the Borg Reinventing the Borg
slightly um I I read something about the
the designer saying basically the BG in
the TV series stuff was attached to them
whereas for the movie we made stuff
coming out of them yeah
[Music]
I subtle difference to the way it was
made but it made them oh my God it made
them so much scary um this was back when
the Bor were actually good before they
ruined them yeah it I mean I actually
don't mind the redesign because in
theory they're always evolving anyway so
they could start to look more different
as they're simulating more races and
then that's how they sort of change um I
I think the problem as you say is that
Voyager really did the B to death
literally um and I think that it's kind
of a bit kind of like too many stories
with them um I think also what gave this
series or this film its own highlights
was it was the first Popa Next
Generation movie on its own it wasn't
tied with the original series um yeah
Alex creger was brilliant as well
as um and um makees sense I suppose what
was that I was thinking about the Nexus
I suppose it does make sense I mean in
the actual what it does I'm think from a
scientific point of view I can't get my
head right now the Nexus would be a
thing but that's
just it supposed to be like another
reality wasn't it or something yeah yeah
it was Subspace anomaly and you go into
it and you exist in the anomaly and in
that when you're inter interacting with
it you see whatever you want it's a bit
magical isn't it it was just it was just
a bit convenient that then you could
appear anywhere in time or space when
you wanted but but yeah and no it was it
worked for the story but anyway go on so
um so I what I liked about also um first
Contact I like the redesigned uniforms
as well I thought those great uniforms
just looked I just gave it a sort of
edgy change to this whole um Next
Generation era more more like a jump
moving away from the jumpsuit and it
felt more well well actually apparently
what they say in Canon is that they went
for the gray uniforms because at that
point the Dominion war was starting up
in the Federation and it was a time of
war and I think that the Federation
decided to be a bit more kind of less
kind of a time of exploration and peace
but more of war and defense and Military
and I think that's why and of course
then I don't know whether that's true or
not but that's what I heard I think a
couple of the actors were getting a
little flabbier in a few places so
decided they realize we need we need
heavier uniforms here oh my good yeah we
thought about that yeah I suppose you're
right yeah
exactly um but um well I mean the first
the first scene a first Contact what the
zoom out from the eye well I mean yeah I
mean that was phenomenal start hearing
the voices I'm going to ignore the fact
that they were at the neutral zone and
then they got to the they got to Earth
within like four minutes I'm going to
ignore
that problem warp varies I mean how fast
you us fantastically but anyway to get
to earth that battle sequence with a
borg is is one of the best in in all the
Star Trek that that battle sequence was
phenomenally good um I absolutely loved
it I I wish it had been a bit longer
you know do you know there's a guy on
YouTube who recently read done the
Battle of War 359 saw yeah I've seen
that it's and it is really good and I'll
tell you what say I actually got a copy
digital copy of Best of Both world my
copy I've mixed in all the footage into
the story and I've got it and it's
really good it's about another 10 15
minutes and I've actually Chopped all
together and made my own special thing
which obviously I can't share but it's
really really good you are but I know I
know but with the um first Contact
though it was a bit short if we could
have like another five minutes of just
the back I mean but then it was yeah
yeah I would I would lik to have been a
bit longer I'd lik to have seen the you
know a little bit more fight the the
Enterprise basically turned a point just
fire on this spot boom it went and I'm
like I'm thinking they could have done a
bit more quick it was yeah but um and
and we never really get any more
fighting after but then you know they
went through the the temple thing and we
saw the the Earth as a borg Planet which
I bifi or whatever the term is yeah the
whole bit with zeph and
Cochran he was great I liked him I think
they got the right actor I think if
they' have got almost anybody else all
the way through I'm going that'll do
what's the what's
the his name but he's yeah he's he's the
guy from babe I'll get his I'll get his
name I can't his name it'll come to
him babe move and that might come up
with a load of adult
stuff
fine um James Cromwell James
Cromwell he's BR and I Hest think he
made it work I think if anybody else had
done that they they they pushed up to
silly I and got the right balance though
over it yeah I agree oh they they just
got the balance right and I thought um
his partner the the girl who's Al Alfrey
Woodard I think her name was I think
yeah well she was phenomenal as well um
liy Sloan liy Sloan ly thank you yeah um
she was so bad oh because I'm looking at
the cast of
Babe um
the so so her character again because
she was such a good actress and her
bouncing off Bard because obviously what
was going on on the planet for me was a
little bit on the ridiculous side it
okay yeah yeah oh no no no but but in in
it could have gone that way really
easily um but with the drama going on on
the Enterprise it balanced it out so
beautifully you know with um with all
the TNG crew on the floor you know on
the on the surface all sort of like
being a bit Star Struck by zephram it
was there was in danger of it getting
into that bit silly area yeah but it
managed to get but it balanced it I just
thought it balanced it beautifully and
now I've lost
you anyway so I don't know who you guys
listening to whether it's me or whether
it's
Mike
um I'd love to know what you guys think
about what is your favorite out of
theing up again you're back you're back
we can hear you anyway um Jonathan
Franks did direct first contact Sarah
was just pointed out as well which is
very true and he then went on to direct
the
um one of the worst movies ever
made uh Fab father what is it
International Rescue Thunderbirds he did
the Thunderbirds movie and that was
painful
um should left fres have Nemesis to yeah
probably good idea but what is the best
out of
the original Star Trek movies the Kirk
movies and then the peard movies so I
mean for me I honestly
think Undiscovered Country for the
original first Contact for the new Trek
films and we've lost mik be back in a
minute um I think that's a no-brainer
and I actually think the worst film for
me is the motion picture from the first
track movies I just I just I just don't
like it and even though five is
ridiculous but I love the whole thing
with the um he's back I I actually five
yeah um Rocco final frontier is his
favorite I think that's Insurrection is
awful so before we talk about star I I
want to talk about Star Trek 5 in a bit
more detail right so I've left it
purposefully okay
um the JJ Abram Star
Treks oh okay what your first instin
what's what's your instinct what what
when I say JJ abam Star Treks what's the
word that jumps into your
brain
mainstream mainstream not mainstream not
official trick re interpretation of tre
not fully understanding Tre yeah I think
well lens flares is the word that jumps
into my brain um lens flares freaking
everywhere um most directors try very
hard to avoid lens flares because it's
considered quite bad you know
directed not JJ Abrams JJ Abrams is like
more lens flares let's throw a few more
in and it's they looking annoying
um I really like the JJ AB movies as
long as I don't think of them as Star
Trek yeah I can go along with that only
think of them as a scifi
movie yeah um
don't when I first watched the beginning
of the first JJ Abraham's movie it
really started off with a lot of action
um with the Calin with the birth of Kirk
and everything and I was really quite
impressed when I watched the the movie
The First Time round
but it's just um from my perspective
that in hindsight it really it really
was its own thing it really was a reboot
whereas all the other previous Star
Treks were a continuation they were all
part of the same universe this was a
reboot the excuse was that it was a
different timeline which it's fair
enough but um it's got a lot of problems
and as one of your um followers saying
that c back as calm was pretty appalling
agree with that how bad a director do
you have to be or a producer whoever to
get Benedict Cumberbatch who is one of
the finest actors of Our Generation he's
a brilliant actor in a it's not a k
though it's not a well in a fantastic
character KH and make him wooden and un
well just
awful and when he does the I am KH bit
you just like going we no we just a
while
ago but the bits that right so if I
think about the JJ Abrams movies as Star
Trek I do get angry so first of all I
think hey Matt De is in the house whoop
you got to start watching these Star
Trek movies mate when you get through
all the series
um they seem to have made the Enterprise
water
powed a brewery well it isn't a brewery
um the whole bit it seemed to be to have
the joke where Scotty beams into the
water pipe and
um but they completely changed the warp
core they seem to make it water like
hydroelectric they seem to make that's
what they seem to be imp yes yeah I can
see
that the way they then they jets in the
warp course at the end but then shoot
off at
warp um well it's like I suppose it was
impulse wasn't it no they warped away I
think they were pushed by the wave
energy wave actually oh no it was it was
a shock wave it pushed it
by the shock wave I think that's what it
was
yeah they
basically they oh the Enterprise
actually all these Flappy bits on the NS
and stuff for no reason they basically
just thought let's just about with
the enter they made the enter Enterprise
mahive much bigger than the original yes
it was bigger than the D actually it was
the same size sort of D size d bigger
than the E yeah yeah it was it's
ridiculously big and JJ ABS did that
it'll look better on IMAX I give a
if he looks better on IMAX he wasn't a
Star Trek fan he said he wasn't actually
he never liked Star Trek he was more of
a Star Wars fan he didn't do too well
with that either but there we go no that
went badly that's a different story um
but I while we cut out though what did
you think about the last two movies of
insurrection and um Nemesis oh yes so um
yeah we'll come back to ABS so Nemesis
um I don't mind Nemesis I don't mind I
don't mind either no I thought it was
good space battle love the space ble I I
like the way they did that um I never
like it when the an Enterprise gets its
ass handed to it but at least they did
that in a better way than they have done
in other films they always make the the
ships weaker they so much weak than
everyone else but yeah it's good um
Insurrection is terrible Insurrection is
the weakest Next Generation movie by far
for me um and um it just didn't work at
all I just
thought the awful it's I mean I I I I
say Star Trek five the final frontier I
like it more than motion
picture it's it's a far worse movie it's
it's it's a awful movie um but I like
bits of it I like the humor and bits of
it I like the um bit with the um I mean
McCoy is fantastic in it you know when
they're doing the like the flashback bit
his oh yes yeah yeah his dad dies and
stuff yeah give the man an Oscar he was
phenomenal um there are bits in that
film I really enjoy and I don't like the
motion picture because I find it boring
but it's a far better movie it feels
more of a it feels sort of bigger scale
doesn't it again it's the pacing cut off
half an hour of it and uh I don't it
could I don't know I think they could I
mean have you seen the director the
redone I'm going to watch the director's
cut it's
on I think it's slightly better I don't
think it's a massive change but it's wor
well worth checking out just to get a
perspective on that movie but for me
final Frontier and Insurrection are by
far they're the awful I say The Good the
Bad and the awful they're the awful um
you know I I almost think of like Star
Trek final frontier as a b movie it's
it's not a good oh yeah it's it's just
nothing it just hasn't got the the
what's required to be a good movie it's
just lacking and an
Insurrection is
just it's border like and then I'm sick
of running from these bastards just I'll
off just yeah yeah that was R in
the bridge wasn't it you said that yeah
it pulls out a joystick like an Atari
with a little red button on top just
like an Atari and then flies through
three-dimensional space it's just no
that's not how anything works it's just
that's what I mean it was just weak it
was weak but um it was so strange
because Jonathan Frank um directed both
that movie and the previous one first
Contact and there were such different
movies so I I think really was down to
just bad writing it just it shouldn't
really have gone past the actual uh you
know sort of early sort of writing ideas
yeah the JJ abrs movies just to just to
run back to those yeah sure do you know
the one thing I thought they got they
did get some things right I thought they
got the casting bang on yeah was
phenomenal um other than
Scotty oh Simon Peg is not SC no um
it's I know why they did it because he
was desperate to appear in it and he
actually wrote um parts of the second
one I think I think he wrote the third
one I think he I think he wrot the third
one Beyond um and
um he he I mean and I know he's
desperate to do it he's just and I love
him as an actor whatever I think he's
fantastic he's but he is not he's not
Scotty um and in it's a shame that that
was the only bit of cast I thought I
thought um Zachary Quinto a spar was
genius I mean it's just that was abely
spawn in um I think it was Insurrection
Beyond uh James duan's son Chris Doan
appeared in the movies and he was
actually on the transporter he was one
of the he was one of the technicians and
of course I've seen James I've seen
James do he played Scotty in the fan
Series start continues so in some ways
it might have been might have been a
good idea to have some who even looks
like the original Scotty perhaps behave
um playing the character rather than
Simon Peg I don't know yeah exactly um
but you know it's it's fine I like him
as I love him as an actor but a lot the
things that I really hate about the JJ
Abrams I I I I think they're action I
think they're fun I think they're
interesting I hate the um interplanet AR
um transp y cheating and it's crap they
used a black hole as a time
machine but they didn't do it correctly
because you can use a black hole as a
time machine in theory time slows down
as in Stargate and all that sort can get
SL close to the but they travel through
it like it's a hole in space the other
end out to the hole and like no
that's
no um oh is it red matter red matter
they used is it R yeah when a
star
explodes unless it's actually the the
Romulan
star how big a supernova was that and
super the shock wave moves at the speed
of light okay right so if it's the star
and we know it wasn't Romulus it wasn't
the Romulan star they say it in the
movie It's not the Romulan star it was
another star apparently oh was Oh I
thought it was Romulus star okay our
nearest star is five years away right
well we know that it wasn't romulus's
star because they had
notice and that actually says that in
Picard season one as well that we them
okay it was the Romulus star it would
have been instantly would have Supernova
would have wiped out the solar system
immediately we wouldn't have had no not
we would have had zero
notice we supposedly had notice of the
the supern noi so that in that case
there must be another star so in that
case they've had at least five years
notice okay you know five light years
away you know Stars aren't much closer
than that there are Supernova that can
wipe out vast areas but it takes a very
long time because the light speed of
light is the limitation of speed you
can't go any faster than that you can't
the shock wave can't travel faster than
that yeah so it should take it's just
the
basic when science fiction yes it should
be fiction yes it should be a story yes
it you should be able to release a bit
you know like the whales thing I can let
that go you know I'm just like yeah
because it's Fiction it's science
fiction the the whole thing with the um
with telepathy and stuff I'm like I can
let that go there's no reason that
couldn't be it's a bit of a stretch
scientifically yeah but you know all
right um the stuff they do in JJ Abram
start TRS I'm just like no you've got
you've you've you've you've took the
science bit and just screwed it up and
going I seem to vaguely remember when I
was at school something about traveling
through black Halls should we do that
yeah that's it that's it that's it
that's the idea done it's just ah but in
classic Tre they didn't they did try I
think his name is Andre Bor or something
he was like a Scientific Advisor and he
would they would actually try to use
ideas fitting in with real science uh
hypthesis
hypothesis D sphere and stuff like that
though yeah that's that's very
fascinating imagine a sort of structure
around a planet around a star then you
could absorb all the energy of that star
and it would be almost unlimited
fascinating that was used in relics in
Next Generation yeah a brilliant episode
with James do exactly one of the best
episodes of of t love that episode um
you know but I I think in a lot of Star
Trek particularly Deep Space 9 and voids
I think they got better as time went on
they took it a little bit more seriously
I think in the first couple of
series not not so much sometimes they
they went a bit it was a bit old school
Star Trek in the first couple of Seasons
but um they always tried they always
made an effort to have at least a nugget
of
scientific either Theory or something at
the core of the story that they then
built the fiction around yeah JJ Abrams
just sort of went I'm just
we just need to write that bit and the
the Enterprise is water powered right
because we found this cool set that
looks like a brewery yeah okay let's do
that and then the warp core is
completely different in the second movie
and completely different in the third
movie which is fine though because the
Enterprise is completely different in
all three films as well it's it's a
different Enterprise it got refit didn't
it it got refit at the end of second one
didn't it it did but they actually
redesigned the Enterprise in the the
second one oh sorry no the third one
they wanted the neck to be thinner and
longer because when the the um Ed the
ships went through the neck there go
eight breaks off so in the second one
though they thought it looked a bit
silly so they actually made it a bit
thicker and Stumpy and they took all the
Flappy bits off the off the engines
notic that I not notic that okay if you
actually look at all three Enterprises
you can they're they're quite
different and and I'm just like why
well they should they shouldn't redesign
the ship for the purpose of a story they
should they should re get the story to
fit that's that's a bit DFT I know
there's a new
Enterprise yeah once you've got a design
of the Enterprise that you should stick
you can't change it I mean they never
did the other series it was always
Enterprise D was the D and the voy and
the Divine and everything else the
movies we had the refit and then it
stayed the same yes it did because it
was a great design and they did it um
you know so
surely I'm sorry mate nothing energy
can't travel faster than the speed of
light I just can't nothing can travel
faster than speed light Theory
relativity that's a fundamental law of
yeah even if it did travel at 10 times
the speed of light which I'm I'm sorry
it can't mate but even if it did you'd
still be talking about a year for it to
travel from a star to the next to to
nearest solar system you'd still be
talking about a long period of time um
the whole point I'm trying to make is
the whole Supernova bit in the first
movie makes no sense from like a
geography point of view is that the
right word cosmological point of view I
don't know because um that so when that
nebula when that uh Sun exploded it
wasn't just one solar system I think if
I remember I think it was a huge part of
space in the Romulan area is that right
it wasn't just one it must have been a
star near Romulus obviously but then
they were going to use the red matter to
collapse the shock wave and that was the
point they were going to use the red
matter to um prevented thing but they
didn't get they didn't do it in time to
protect Romulus okay in the movie andan
again that makes no sense either um but
you know it's just like I stretch I'll
talk about stretching
everything in the third movie Idis El's
character doesn't make a lot of sense
he's phenomenal powerful considering
he's just been locked on that planet and
he's built an incredibly powerful Fleet
of
Warships
um I also didn't like the space base I
hated that space base oh Yorktown
Yorktown was called yeah yorkt was just
stupid um I hate that well it didn't fit
in with I mean that time I mean you had
obviously star bases in the original
series and everything else and even Next
Generation although it's an alternate
timeline that thing was like
yeah that was a bit sort all over the
top wasn't it yeah I I those domes all
the trees and everything I did like the
bit where the Enterprise sort of goes
into Dock and it was going under the
water underneath the thing yeah yeah it
made no sense that they would do that
because that's a very big tunnel to
build for no reason for one ship just to
go but it looked cool yeah it's a great
visual thing yeah I mean that's a
problem with the JJs I mean sometimes
they just do stuff just to make it look
cool even if it doesn't make any sense
at all yeah and it's maddening because
it's not Tre and that's what's really
mad I mean don't get me wrong Star Trek
just stuff to look cool um the engine
you know and and the and the Enterprise
D I mean I'm there's no reason why that
light's going up and down and stuff I
don't think but it looked cool um and um
you know there's there's stuff like that
because obviously it's still a it's
still a TV show it's still got to look
cool but I think they just take it to an
extreme with this go like okay this
doesn't make sense that the Enterprise
would do this
but screw it let's do it anyway
yeah and Idis alur's
um the whole storyline with this Albert
just didn't make sense well he because
he was like an alien and then he sort of
starts old I think I is that actually
said in the movie that it's an old that
he actually acquired the ships from
another civilization I don't remember
that maybe he did I I can't remember the
actual I I thought I if he did I would
have probably remembered that myself but
maybe did I know there's a device isn't
there that he uses and that's why he how
he survives and that's why he changes so
much yeah the technology so is that that
that's it then there's an ancient
civilization and he absorbs he just uses
their technology then okay that makes a
little bit more sense I don't think
explained very well in the movie but I'm
G this is the whole point of what we're
doing we're going to watch these films
again and we're going to rate them um
because yeah it's been a long time since
I watched it um I I didn't hate that
film at all I I actually I I quite liked
it when they hit the music and they
go that
again visually very cool um on the uh
had a nice sort of link to the nxo1 sort
of Enterprise era as well which I
thought was a nice little I like
that slightly different class vessel
apparently I think yeah I mean it was
the Franklin or was it Franklin Franklin
but you could tell it was from that era
from the which which actually was before
was before the split into the Kelvin
timeline in the first J I like that
because it splits off and I just as a
geek I like that kind of thing so yeah
that's all right well I mean so yeah um
the second
movie I quite like the second movie
other
than Benedict K match isn't
KH I didn't like that Kirk died and they
did they did a reversal of the uh the
the the scene in the engineering where
in ratha KH it spot was dying and then
they and then I didn't like that I just
thought that was a bit DED I didn't
think that easy yeah
um it didn't they didn't need to do that
and then the whole thing with his blood
like no Kirk was
dead he wasn't poorly he was died dead
and never getet the brain needs oxygen
if four minutes if you stop breathing
you're going to die that's it you'll get
brain damage so but no has magic blood
piss no no he doesn't have magic blood
um so then that was stupid as well again
that was I like I like the Vengeance
though and section 31 was also sort of
involved with which I thought was quite
a nice time with I love I love I love
RoboCop as the Admiral oh um what's his
name I love the Vengeance I do know his
is really cool yeah um I do know his
name Paul Weller no that's no not Paul
well
Paul oh I'm not things come on somebody
tell us please I'm gon to go with Paul
Weller until somebody corrects me
because it's it's bloody close to
that oh shoot I'm not GNA look it up no
somebody will get into the comments and
tell us in a second because the our our
community is fantastic that actor also
appeared on Enterprise pet Peter well
sorry thank you very damn close come on
I was very damn close Clos than I was
hard is to go live doing these videos
think as well at the same time pretty
impressive
uh I I amaz myself
sometimes um yeah but so JJ Abrams good
films fun movies not Star Trek I agree
basically it's a shame it's a shame so I
think we can ignore them so can I not
watch them when we do
this this this this reviewing all the
movies that we're going to do can we
ignore
them I don't mind we can we can I mean I
I know the one enough to probably I
could review it without having to
rewatch it I would say we got do it we
got do if we're going to do it we'll do
it properly all right so we're coming up
to the end of so we got a couple of
minutes left okay we're going to rate
these movies and I want you guys in the
community to help us with this right so
I think first of all we'll rate
everything out of five five five
points just to keep it simple five yeah
okay so I think first of all I'm
throwing in the Kirk rating and the Kirk
rating is
basically
um action or
fun action should do action because he
shoots
first so we're gonna be rating the
action in the movies as the Kirk rating
right guys tell me in the comments yeah
happy with that you know yes
know does the story make sense is it
logical
the Spock rating
okay and
uh okay uh well you're breaking up a
minute so give me a second it's it's
slowing down but um yeah I'm not sure I
mean so are we do so are we just the the
whole film so are we going to do like
the first film of Kirk and then we'll do
how do you want to do it we'll do them
in order so we'll start with the motion
picture all right we'll go we'll burn
through we are rating them compared to
each other right so not compared to like
other we're not comparing them to um I
don't know Heat or the Sha Shank
Redemption we're we're rating them
compared to each other all right okay
all right so we've got the Kirk rating
action the spot rating is the story
logical
okay um I think how about the uru rating
for the writing
yeah okay the communication lady okay
how good how good the writing is so
action logical writing okay yeah
[Music]
um what's next what's
next what else is that you got to rate
in a movie we got to do an over oh sorry
overall I think it should be the rodeny
rating what you think overall let's do
yeah that's four okay overall rating
that sounds good that makes sense okay
Roden
what about just actual enjoyment just
just like enjoy it good feel to it just
an enjoyment Factor what character is
full of life of Joy Barkley enjoyment
rating or no he's not a movie character
is he I don't know what should do as a
as a comedy character bones was pretty
sort of like um full of life sort of
thing AR he yeah all right let's go with
bones yeah go bones for fun okay well
we're keeping all original original
characters here yeah yeah sorry yeah we
should yeah maybe we should carry on I'm
not doing that on purpose but it seems
to be no but we're kind of we're getting
towards getting stuck in that sort of
like well we don't have to but we can
about we could even do then just finally
a Scotty rating is like how clever that
be technical cleverness technical
technicalities yeah Technic all right
okay yeah all right the Scotty rated all
right guys in the comments are we happy
with these I think I I think I um the
only rating I care about is do I like it
or hate it yeah but there are there are
levels of like or hate so we're gonna go
with
levels um so the Scotty rating for like
technical so I mean that's a little bit
different from the the logic so does the
story make sense but then we're going to
do sort of like you know the sciencey
bit the JJ Abrams on on the Scotty
rating are going to do
bad
um with the story stories might be more
logical you just if you just take out
the
science anyway so I think we have those
five ratings okay we then take the we
take the points from each one divide it
by five and that gives us our rodeny
rating and we can work it out okay and
then we get that's way we get four for
each movie and we will at the end of
this be able to tell you which is the
best and which is the worst of all the
St movie Yes based on the Roden rting ma
matically yeah yeah that's
scienced godamn it
um the check off rating how many times
is the word wles of wles
mentioned it should maybe be check off
for the comedy rating because he he is
funny yeah
right Mike thank you so much sir um for
our first point celebration of um Star
Trek we will be back in the next couple
of weeks to do
the first
movie do it whenever we can yeah we'll
go through it I know that one or two
races for the first movie I can already
see what they're going to be but we'll
when we get there we'll obviously but
that should be interesting so I I
planning on doing it every every two
weeks is it you want to do is that what
you're planning on doing couple weeks
like you said when we can but yeah we'll
we'll try and do it regular yeah I'll
try and do it regular time slot if we
can that'd be great so fantastic um
we've had well over 30 people watching
the whole video on my end I don't know
about your end but that's done I'm
really really pleased by that guys thank
you so much um come and join us again in
a couple of weeks and um that's that's
goodbye for me and goodbye for me thank
you very much we'll see you next time
see you later mate have a good one good
night guys
cheers